bitcoin mining is the most lucrative use
of energy in the world oh that's hands
down in the world right very provable
and very verifiable in the world and
it's it's the best use of intermittent
energy and the best use of sustainable
energy when you look at it that way you
know you're thinking shouldn't we expect
an avalanche more of political support
and the answer is yes and and why is it
stable it's stable because the bitcoin
miner is gonna and the bitcoin holders
are gonna go wherever the politicians
support them and they're going to bring
their capital and they're going to pay
taxes large sums of taxes the right way
to think about bitcoin is bitcoin's
creating an opportunity it's an
opportunity for your family to save
money for 100 years it's an opportunity
to fix your company microstrategy stock
is hitting 800 right it's it's an
opportunity for your shareholders it's
an opportunity for your taxpayers it's
an opportunity for your constituents
it's an opportunity in the media
business right i mean
nobody wants to talk about anything but
bitcoin
everyone wants to talk about bitcoin
it's an opportunity for twitter it's an
opportunity for every mobile app
what i think people don't recognize and
you and if i talked about this before is
um
it's the only thing from a strategic
standpoint that if you're an individual
you can plug in your personal balance
sheet right you can start to run your
own node you can uh use this technology
if you're a corporation or a financial
institution you can plug your business
into the network and you can do that in
a multitude of ways you can build
services that end up facilitating other
people to use it or
you can mine to support the network you
can simply just buy the asset and hold
it on your balance sheet but you can
plug in it's also true of nation states
and foundations and endowments and
pension funds etc but when you plug into
the network you're in essence hiring
tens of millions if not hundreds of
millions of people around the world that
are all now working aligned with you to
further your business right i talk all
the time about whether you're a
restaurant right where we've literally
seen examples of many restaurants who
have done this all the way up to large
pension funds or nation states
all of a sudden the the cyber hornets
online they begin to rally around you
they begin to push you forward they
begin to say hey we will support you
because you are like-minded like us you
are also helping us move this forward
but you also get the support of every
single minor in the world they'll say we
will protect your economic wealth for
you and you get the lightning network we
will help people actually route these
transactions it's just a very unique
thing where you're essentially hiring so
many people and so much economic value
but all you do is you just plug in right
you don't have to go meet these people
you don't even know who they are it's an
it's an excellent political strategy
it's an excellent marketing strategy
it's an excellent shareholder relations
strategy it's an excellent business
strategy
uh it's
i guess there's two thoughts i have here
one
properly understood
i believe bitcoin is digital energy it
is pure energy right it's not digital
gold that's put a billion dollars of
money in a vault and i'll sit there for
a decade and you can't do anything with
it it's it's it's not even digital
property digital property is a billion
dollars of a digital hotel and i can
teleport it from new york to paris and
back again and it's maintenance free and
indestructible it's better than that
it's digital energy because i can
decompose the hotel to room minutes
and i can i can decompose and recompose
this pure energy hotel and rent it out
at the speed of light and program it
with a million transactions a second you
never saw a hotel get programmed with a
billion parts a million transactions a
second it's literally like a swirling
energy mass
when you understand that
then you see
it hasn't eliminated capitalism it's
simply the 500
trillion dollar digital energy basis of
capitalism
it makes sense that you would use it as
the foundation to build your family to
build your company to build your country
to build your city to build your
application to build your device you can
put it into everything and now
once you've done that
look you can back up your your family
with the balance sheet of bitcoin you'll
be rich that doesn't mean you'll be
happy there's a lot of rich families
that have a lot of messed up problems
right you can watch them on television
you know you can put it on the balance
sheet of your company you know
i have you know seven if i have seven or
eight billion dollars on my balance
sheet that doesn't mean i don't have to
get up and go to work and make the
software work and sell the software and
listen to the customers i'm still in a
in a um competitive struggle with other
like-kind software companies it's all
business intelligence software and the
same is true with your city right
it's half the solution the other half of
the solution is you need rational
policies at the municipal level the
state level and the government level so
when you think about it like that
right
you realize that um
it it just it makes sense
and it's uh it's going to grow
but um
what was the second part of your
question again in terms of as more and
more people plug into this system do we
expect not only one the politicians
obviously will continue to do this but
is there a spillover effect where people
actually leave jurisdictions that aren't
bitcoin friendly like there's an element
of take taxes right there's a carrot and
a stick you can drop your tax rates you
can incentivize people to move but you
also could increase your taxes and
literally push people away
it's obvious that the incentive to get
people to move to your jurisdiction but
if people continue to be abrasive is
there problems yeah yeah i remember what
i was going to say now it's
the energy system is an energy network
everyone's plugging into it and it makes
them
more efficient than they would otherwise
be but they still have their struggle
what's happening is
yeah you're benefiting from the rest of
the network
you can't afford to to lose laser-like
focus on your family or company or
country right
you can't assume that just because you
plugged into bitcoin networks you can be
a crappy retailer or a bad mayor or a
bad father right so it doesn't solve
that problem
every i think we boil down to
a simple idea which is everybody's got a
balance sheet everybody's got a p l the
p l is your operating business you
better be the best in the world at that
thing
the best in the world if you get
distracted
you know you want to be a good husband
you can't have six wives
yeah you want to be a good retailer you
better know who your customer is you
still compete against every retail so
you're operating
business you got to be really laser-like
and good at it but
by plugging your uh your balance unit a
bitcoin
you have
hundreds of millions of people guarding
your back
that are energizing the network
and
you know it takes me back to a historic
observation history teaches us
that the winning civilizations the
winners in the history of mankind
are the civilizations that channel
energy more effectively through time and
space right and and that
means practically speaking right the
romans
they were good at killing people
it's not easy to kill people right i
mean to raise an army they didn't show
up with bows and arrows and spears they
showed up with industrial grade
artillery that tossed 50 pound flaming
balls of shrapnel at you from 500 meters
or a thousand meters away right and a
navy so
so uh you see that over and over again
right
steel
trumps
iron and iron trumps bronze
and that's because and bronze trumps
stone
right you pick up a stone if you're if
you pick up the sharp rock you beat the
other guy if you're smart enough to pick
up a rock and the other guy didn't pick
up a rock you won the fight if you had
the had the iron then you beat the guys
with the bronze if you had the steel you
beat the guys the br with the the iron
you ever seen steel forged
people don't think about this walk into
a steel mill look around what do you
think is going on
right
there they're channeling immense energy
right that the fire the heat you know or
electric electric rolled steel
massive energy into metallic form
air power is energy potential energy you
get up 50 000 feet you drop someone on
someone's head
okay what's the channeling part remember
the gulf war they had you know norm
schwarzkopf used to show the videos of
the laser-guided bomb and something
that's in the clouds dropped the bomb
that managed to hit
you know a three by three
space
from fifty thousand feet up you know
through the wind
right so
the channeling of the energy through
time and space
you know and and being better at
channeling it that explains why every
team wins in sports that's why tom brady
wins because the quarterback puts you
seen he put the football
in exactly the spot you have to put that
football in that space in a plus or
minus 10 millisecond
time spot with the right uh with the
right spin on the ball and if you happen
to be able to do that you can win and is
it random no
it's not random there's one but one guy
that's better at it than everybody else
and he and if he didn't have the team
they wouldn't win so
every winner
is better at channeling energy and time
and space every civilization every city
every company
right
every investor
so the real power of bitcoin is bitcoin
is digital energy
and until you figure it out if i said to
you what is digital energy well digital
energy is i'm gonna put a hundred
billion dollars
into this container and then i'm going
to do a magic trick and it's not here
anymore but guess what i can move it at
the speed of light a billion times a
second and you can't find it and i can
put it into every car and it'll drive
every car on the planet for the next two
years without fuel
sounds like a magic spell
but it is a magic spell any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from magic
bitcoin's digital energy
the next best thing is electrical energy
it's not you know information these are
not nearly as good it's a thousand times
better than the thing it's replacing